[Music]
it's pft ot a friday edition and we've
had chris sims on several recent fridays
but today i will fly solo as we get
through some of the things we either
didn't address during pft live or things
i would like to take
a closer look at i want to start with
pat bolan who died overnight at the age
of 75. he had been the owner of the
denver broncos since
1984
seven super bowl appearances during his
tenure as owner of the team and only
seven losing seasons in 35 years as the
owner one of the issues that we pointed
out last year first time since the early
70s the broncos had back-to-back losing
seasons that's how relevant they have
been
over the last five decades and over the
last three and a half decades it's been
pat bolan as owner of the team and it
wasn't just his contributions to the
broncos it was his contributions to the
national football league he served on
various committees he was involved in
labor negotiations and he was closely
involved in the creation of sunday night
football not sunday night football as we
saw it in the 80s but sunday night
football as became in 2006 when nbc
purchased the rights to the package away
from espn and espn slid into the monday
night football spot
because at that moment
the biggest prime time event of the week
for the nfl went from monday to sunday
it's the broadcast game it's the big
game and it's the game that now has the
flex option that we saw used multiple
times just last year it ensures that
there's always going to be
a compelling game late in the season
when that option is there to slide a
better game in and a lesser game out pat
bolan one of the key architects of what
became nbc's offer to take sunday night
football and make it into something
extremely special and for eight straight
years sunday night football has been the
number one show in prime time and pat
bolland the person most responsible for
the creation of that franchise so a
great owner a great legacy
struggles with alzheimer's disease in
his later years and wasn't involved in
the management of the team over the last
five years he had turned the team over
to a group of trustees but pat bowling
the person who bought that team and and
made it one of the best franchises in
the national football league and helped
make the national football league a lot
better than it was before he arrived as
an owner and he will enter the pro
football hall of fame in august
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports